it has taken
232 years and 115
prior appointments
for a black woman
to be selected to serve on the supreme
court of the united states
and reflecting on her own personal story
in my family it took just one generation
to go from segregation to the supreme
court of the united states
soon to be justice katanji brown jackson
celebrated her confirmation by thanking
her supporters biggest of all her
daughters and her husband patrick i
don't know that i believed you when you
said that i could do this but now i do
also among the attendees members of the
president's cabinet and congress and
dozens of women of color who see
themselves in judge jackson you will
inspire
generations
of leaders we're going to look back and
see this as a moment of real change
judge jackson replaces justice stephen
breyer after he retires this summer when
he does it will be the most diverse
supreme court in its history with three
justices of color and four women it is
an honor
the honor of a lifetime for me to have
this chance to join the court judge
jackson is set to hear arguments on
several major issues next term including
voting rights and electoral maps
religious liberty and lgbtq rights